foreign
do you know the story of the princess
Issa
[Music]
she was called the redeem
it was said this child would stop the
madness of War
in a new age of peace and compassion
I was given memories of a world I will
never see
loyalty to a King I cannot serve
and love for a child
I could not save
D what do you think they want
I found her
a skull Giver
I am a child of War
I was taught that love is weakness
there is a difference between Justice
and revenge
very surprised to pay for your defiance
[Applause]
one moment
I do love this part
hold on
I don't want no trouble
we're not here to bring any
are you ready
We're Not Afraid
showing them we're more than the
shackles that bind us
[Music]
the king is a man and a man can feel
but a myth is indestructible
[Music]
the time has come for all that you love
protect each other we show them your
mercy
[Music]
who among you is willing to die for what
you believe
[Applause]
[Music]